what you're meant to this video I'm
playing Coriolanus is this a brand new
handle yes um this is a totally new
annual the first five minute game that
this guy is playing funny and what is
this you have other ratings 1600 and
Blitzen let's see what happens playing
for a quick queenside initiative that's
quite good here with b5 this type of
this type of setup it's not so well
known but it's quite ok like this
getting an early even queenside
expansion so i gained some space ok so
i'll fix the structure here amazing why
not just recapture ok let's develop
maybe we should be seven oz better but
ok already already played yeah Bishop f4
maybe because of this I should have
played Bishop e7 now I can actually try
to uc3m this is weakness
should I take or not so i can play look
see it first maybe then take
take and Queen B 6 should be three Queen
f6 threatening here does not make much
sense i guess if i take on e5 and play
Knight c3 is this a strong pawn or a
week pawn not clear come on let's let's
prepare it takes takes Knight x and then
f queen before to support it let's let's
go for that now not trying to reinvent
the wheel just play good news and I've
got green be for now to support my pawn
this was the idea of Queen seven yeah
like this yeah but this is just noise
IAM to those points the airport it's not
too much of a problem i guess i can go
d43 this idea maybe also d for Bishop c4
the right moment I do that ev3 there's
d3 this is this is nice really maybe I
can get n Bishop c4 yeah interesting i
can play I 1g5
g5 and f6 break up the structure
yeah I wonder about this Bishop c4 idea
take the vid takes it be three SS very
strong but it's not it's not winning
it's just strong maybe improve the
position of it it's not like you can do
much you really cant cannot take because
of roxy 585 would be overwhelming
I'm trying to combine player with the
queenside advantage to go the Kings side
like king of seven taking and maybe a
rook G a G for maneuver attacking our
form could be nice maybe rook c7 G seven
for that matter I hope drug c7 could be
a useful move in any case ads they're
very tricky to play for him and now i
have d three ok i'm going to take it
first and d3 is this winning d three
takes Bishop takes rook see one should
be four maybe but don't really see he
cannot really improve his position very
much I can first first improve my in a
bit
not totally sold on d3 it is probably
good but still wonder if I have some
better continuation maybe maybe started
this Bishop c4 idea still fascinates me
d 3 there's no non-threatening this for
real Bishop c4 takes be three Roxy 1 B 2
and I'm promoting okay and now I can go
him you know you know this is strong
rook be one i have d 3 this is a big
point takes Bishop takes and I'm winning
the exchange and winning the exchanges
are also the game has he cannot he
cannot stop the pawns quite resigned
yeah for Sonny's challenge no I'm not
going to play rematch here the Blitz
poor um yeah this was now this position
was very nice and advanced ports are
always stay in the Lisbon I probably had
something quicker but um yeah five g5
looks like strategically well or founded
yeah the computer plays Bishop c4 even
here yeah it looks yeah looks like it
should be working but I wanted to
prepare it around here let's let's see
how is this this exactly winning yeah I
know it looks it looks very dangerous
but I Roxy for simply taking and then
okay yeah and then b2 and c2 this is
this is so not difficult really we
haven't okay
I thought I can play some more prep
moves and he can really not it's not
you're able to prevent it in any way
this is now I'm getting very very nicely
with those pawns yeah I think some
whatever hellmich mismatch you don't see
a 700 rating difference that often in 95
minute but is this is also a case where
this was his first game so I'm not sure
how they pair this alright thanks for
watching